Hi there!
I’ve been active in what you might call
the field of artificial intelligence for a
while now.
Of course, Ms. Coffee Bean knew everything
about the technology behind AI-based search
engines,
but I honestly didn’t have any deeper thoughts
about what it means to actually implement
a search engine, ever!
But I was approached by SeMI Technologies
that made an open-source vector search engine
called Weaviate.
[scratched disk sound] A vector whaat?
Yes, exactly.
In this video we will explain the general
mechanism of modern search engines.
It’s especially important to know if I am
ever going to make my private custom search
engine for my super-secret Ms. Coffee Bean
data.
Starting from the data, we will go through
and explain the most important steps:
transforming the database into a vector database
with a machine learning model like FastText
or Tarnsformers;
then querying the database.
Thanks to SeMI Technologies for sponsoring
this educational video!
Ms. Coffee Bean are you ready to do the explainy
bits?
Ok, let’s go!
Search engines are the algorithms helping
you search over large sets of documents or
other kinds of data – and do it fast.
These documents can be either from the Internet
or the documents a company or organization
has on their private servers.
When search engines first appeared, they were
not the “clever” AI-powered beasts of
today – we’ll get to those in a minute.
The first search engines were relatively simple
implementations of full-text-based search.
This is very similar to how we look something
up in a dictionary: If you searched for “computer”,
the algorithm behind the search engine went
and matched strings to find occurrences of
the word “computer” on the Internet (or
text database).
There were clever tricks: For example, to
generalize from “computers” to “computer”,
word inflections got removed.
Or simple word distances were employed – that
you also see in spell-checkers
– like the Levenshtein metric that measures
the minimum number of single-character edits
needed to change one word into the other.
But you see, there are many reasons to let
these search engines evolve into something
smarter.
What if, with “computer” I do not search
for a PC or Mac or a compute cluster, but
what was originally meant by the word computer:
a human person – usually a woman – that
used to do computations before digital computers
were invented.
In this ambiguous case, how should the search
algorithm know which meaning of the word I
intended?
Taking the most frequent meaning would make
the search engine insensitive to rarer use
cases of words.
Even more, think of what happens if I search
something that is not even retrievable by
simple string matching, like when I ask a
question: Who is the one who has the most
money?
How should the string-matching algorithm know
that “most money” means “richest”
or that “the one” refers to “Coffee
Beans”?
Or even worse, what if we try to do an image
search?
These two images might look the same, but
if we look closer,
bit by bit, they are different because the
same content is encoded differently.
So, if we search for an image in a database
or on the internet, we might quickly fail
if we just match strings.
We need a search engine that is more than
just a dictionary lookup and is aware of content
and context.
So let’s bring in the heavy artillery of
today’s AI-powered search engines.
Well, “AI” is a little of a buzzword here:
calling them for what they really are,
modern search engines are vector search engines
over vector databases.
Vector databases are a way of organizing the
documents in the database – in meaningful
vectors! – to be able to search through
them with queries that are vectorized beforehand
too.
In contrast, things in a dictionary are organized
alphabetically, which makes sense when searching
by string-matching.
But vector databases allow us to organize
things even better: based on the context in
which information finds itself.
So, we have a new system for organizing our
database (or the indexed Internet), based
on the principle of context:
words that occur in the same context, belong
together.
We have here two examples of how words that
are different, live in the same context.
It becomes clear that the computer which I
turned off, is different from the computer
as the job description that Ms. Coffee Bean’s
grandmother had.
Of course, one example is often not representative,
so we look at more and more examples like
these,
and we can set up a graph where “computer”
is close to “PC” and “Mac”
and the jobs are close to “computer” too,
but “PC” and the jobs should be farther
away from one another.
If we take in all the other words used on
all webpages or in our own database, we can
grow a big graph.
A dictionary was in a sense one-dimensional,
as things follow one another only alphabetically:
the first character was our only feature.
But now we organize our database entries in
this graph where things have more than one
feature: one feature might be describing how
much of a “job” something is;
the other feature might describe how human
something is -- from "0 human to very human".
With each feature or dimension that we add,
the more characteristics we can assign for
a data point.
Therefore, to what we have cramped here into
a two-dimensional visualization, we can actually
give more space,
where all the features, possibly hundreds,
each occupy a dimension in a vector space
to really flesh out the complex contextual
relationships.
Hereby, each word becomes a vector encoding
the exact position of the word in this high-dimensional
space.
To explain this on even higher levels: Imagine
you’re going to the supermarket:
in the classical search engine case, it’s
like the supermarket was a long row of products
all organized after the first letter in the
alphabet.
But the problem there is, that if we go and
find the apples, next to the apples there
are bongos
and not other fruit like pears or strawberries.
Modern vector databases are just giving things
more space, for modelling relationships better.
In each vector we can store the position of
each data point in this vector space encoding
complex relationships in between.
So after we encoded everything in a meaningful
vector, we now have a vector database.
And of course, we do not have to do this encoding
of words into vectors by hand and we also
do not have to come up with features or vector
entries ourselves,
because there are readily available machine
learning models for this.
Proprietary search engines, of course do not
let you choose the vectorizer.
But customizable search engines like Weaviate
do give you the choice: you could take their
custom one based on FastText called the Contextionary,
or the Transformers module, or a ResNet (for
images), or you could add your own machine
learning models to vectorize with.
But for this explanation, we will resort to
Ms. Coffee Bean’s favorite vectorization
method:
transformers that are state-of-the-art at
this.
They are reading in lots of documents, like
your whole database, the whole Wikipedia or
the whole Internet – not kidding.
After they have read in all sentences in the
input data,
they corrupt their input by deleting words
and then they try to reconstruct those words.
The words are all represented by random vectors
at first, so initially the output looks random
too.
But example after example, these transformers
start to learn something about language by
deleting, reconstructing words, and updating
their vectors to better – many many times,
until they start to encode patterns in context-dependent
vectors.
These patterns reflect which words occur together
in these many, many sentences, and which context
words have.
A kind of self-organization occurs where vectors
in this vector space start to cluster together
based on how their respective words behaved
in the input data.
Such a model has to be trained once and we
can now feed any kind of text into it, without
the need of retraining and can encode our
whole database.
Now, with all the words indexed in our database
in vector form, we can take in our query,
pass it through the same model to produce
us vectors for the query too.
And now we can compare the vectors.
If we search for “female computer” the
vector for “computer” in the query is
informed by its context “female”,
therefore, we will retrieve the database entries
that also figure the word computer in the
same job context.
Through the same mechanism, we can answer
questions too.
The cool thing is that what we have explained
here with text is possible with images, videos,
speech or other kinds of data too, especially
because these vectorizing models, the transformers,
can handle all these kinds of data to compute
content and context-aware vectors.
For more about this, watch some of our videos
on multimodality.
Well, this is what happens on a high level
in AI-powered search engines.
Yeah, it’s cool especially because it does
not need human supervision that would be impossible
at these large scales, but admittedly it’s
less magical when one really knows what happens,
right?
We are not really telling you that the Google
or Bing or any other search engines work exactly
this way:
The algorithms behind them are proprietary
and not disclosed.
But judging by their capabilities and especially
their failure modes, there is a definitely
a vector database and a vector search engine
behind them.
The real lessons about these modern, vector
search engines, we can know from OPEN-source
projects.
Weaviate is such an open-source vector search
engine.
You know, OPEN, where can one inspect the
code, open the documentation.
This is important to have not only because
you know what is going on in there, but also
in the situation when you are a company or
an institution with millions of documents
and want to search through them.
For example, what if you are a hospital with
millions of clinical data samples?
Or a factory with product data?
Or a shop with lots of customer data?
Post all your data on the Internet to be searchable
by Google Search?
Of course, that’s a no-go.
It's estimated that more than 99% of data
is not publicly available, so if you possess
a part of that data, you would either have
to implement a search engine yourself
or take and contribute to the open-source
work that was already done.
Having control about the search engine on
your data is important also concerning the
vectorizing model we talked about just before,
that takes in data and transforms it into
vectors.
Because that model is good with types of data
it has already seen.
If it was trained on webpages, it is good
at judging internet forum text, normal websites,
but what if you have technical engineering
terms or medical data in your database?
In this case, you need to take this model
and fine-tune it on that medical data, meaning
that you train it further by showing it medical
text.
It takes it in and self-trains by following
the same procedure as before: it deletes words
and tries to reconstruct the text based on
the corrupted version only.
This then lets it extract patterns on this
new domain of data, like medical texts, or
other domains.
Weaviate even has a simpler solution where
for every undefined word, you can provide
the definition of that word and use this as
context, and you do not need to further train
anything.
So to recapitulate what we need for a vector
search engine:
First, we need the data, then we need the
machine learning model (like the transformer
but doesn’t need to)
which we use to vectorize the data, so our
database is now a vector database.
And we are ready to search through it!
All we need is a query that we should also
vectorize with the same machine learning model
because we now want to ask which vector in
the database is closest to our query.
But Ms. Coffee Bean is not the best coder
when it comes to handling tons of data without
running out of memory and waiting for ages
for the search to complete.
Searching through a lot of data fast is not
an easy thing, admittedly, so here is where
she wants to rely on Weaviate
that has already figured it out how to scale
the vector search for millions of vectors
in milliseconds.
Okay, Ms. Coffee Bean, you are allowed to
check it out!
I mean, why not, it’s open source after
all!
So now, Ms. Coffee Bean, are you ready to
find out the truth?
We need to ask: “Where can I get the best
coffee for my AI coffee break?”
Aa, around the globe.
Exactly, that’s the spirit!
We hope you liked our explanation of modern
search engines in general.
If you are interested in a more technical
presentation about Weaviate in particular,
check out the video in the upper right corner
– also linked in the description below.
[whisper] Do not forget to like and subscribe!
See you!
Okay, bye!